le plan alerte enlèvement a été
déclenché pour la première fois en
france après la disparition de deux
fillettes dans le maine et loire les
enfants sont saines et sauves
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
indiquent qu'il n'y aurait pas eu de
kidnapping en sibérie un airbus a pris
feu ce matin à l'atterrissage dix
personnes seulement sont sortis indemnes
on déplore 140 victimes de nombreux
blessés
en cause une possible panne du système
de freinage dans le sud de l'alerté à la
canicule était tendu un troisième
département sont donc concernés par une
vigilance orange le gard des bouches du
rhône et le vaucluse
mardi on s'attend à des pointes à 38°
une vague de chaleur qui pourrait durer
jusqu'à jeudi
la finale hommes de wimbledon c'est
roger federer qui a remporté le tournoi
pour la quatrième fois de suite
il a battu rafael nadal en quatre sets
6/0 7/6 6/7 6/3 et puis du cinéma avec
la sortie du premier film sur les
attentats du 11-septembre vol 93 raconte
le courage de ses passagers qui ont
tenté de prendre le contrôle de l'avion
qui s'est écrasé en pennsylvanie
une reconstitution qui se veut très
réalise pas là monsieur bonsoir dans
l'actualité de ce dimanche deux
fillettes disparues dans le
maine-et-loire depuis hier ont été
retrouvés en bonne santé
l'afer a été prise très au sérieux par
les gendarmes et la justice et pour la
première fois en france le plan alerte
enlèvement a été déclenché en milieu de
matinée mais finalement d'après les
premiers éléments de l'enquêté il ne
s'agirait pas d'enlèvement romual bonnan
fabien delory
depuis 11h ce matin emeline et mélissa
les deux fillettes de 8 et 10 ans qui
avait disparu hier après-midi ont
finalement retrouvé leur maison de
bouillé ménard un dénouement heureux est
plus rapide que prévu qui a soulagé les
habitants de la commune où on dit
qu'elles sont vivantes et était quelque
part mais bon on s'attendait au pire un
enfant ont été très marqués les
investigations avec 250 gendarmes
avaient été diligentées après l'alerté
lancée par la mère de mélissa emeline et
aussi surtout après le témoignage d'une
enfant de 10 ans qui avait repéré un
homme avec un tatouage de bélier sur le
bras tentant d'en mener les deux
fillettes contre leur gré
un témoin qui depuis a avoué avoir menti
en réalité c'est une mère de famille
d'une trentaine d'années qui a ramené
les deux fillettes
elle venait de passer la nuit chez elle
pour une soirée entre copines de classe
elle nous indique que la maman ya
consenti et que c'est dans ces
conditions là qu'elle est partie avec
les enfants alors à nous à préciser
quand même pour expliquer un petit peu
le tout qu'apparemment lorsqu'elle est
arrivée donc la maman était sous
l'empiré d'un état alcoolique une mer
fragile et un faux témoignage qui ont eu
pour conséquence le déclenchement du
plan alerte enlèvement par le procureur
de la république
un principe de précaution pour la
justice mais un véritable emballement
aux yeux de la jeune mère de famille qui
avait accueilli comme prévu mélissa et
emeline ça c'est sûr enfin pour ma part
en tous les cas ça a été beaucoup trop
rapide et qui n'importe quoi puisque
puisqu'il serait bienvenu quoi elle
était invitée comme eu plein de filles
femmes plein d'autres petites filles
mélissa et emeline qui seront prises en
charge par les services sociaux
d'ici quelques jours le système alerte
enlèvement créée aux états unis puis au
québec a donc été activé pour la
première fois en france dans la matinée
une décision qui a été prise sans
précipitation en toute connaissance de
cause indique la procureure tous les
critères étaient remplis même s'il s'est
avéré plus tard qu'il ne s'agissait pas
de kidnapping au régime à arnaud vers 10
heures ce matin les grandes chaînes
françaises interrompre leurs programmes
enfant a été enlevé
ceci est une alerte enlèvement du
ministère de la justice
magie c'est pas celle pour la première
fois en france le plan alerte enlèvement
est déclenché photo freinons âge
circonstances de la disparition moins de
12 heures après le signalement un
message est diffusé en bas des écrans de
télévision sur les radios et les
panneaux routiers l'alertent at-elle été
lancé prématurément
non
je pense que ce dispositif s'il doit
fonctionner doit être mis en place très
rapide tu penses que le principe
élémentaire de précaution et de lancer
l' alerte enlèvement avéré mineur en
danger éléments concrets à diffuser et à
corps des parents de la victime
les critères obligatoires qui ont décidé
le parquet d'angers a donné l alerte
une précaution qui selon le père
d'estelle mouzin disparue il ya trois
ans et de toute façon la meilleure
solution
il ya un travail d'apprentissage qui est
à faire avec je l'espère le une cellule
de débriefing qui sera mise en place et
qui tirera les enseignements des mises
en oeuvre aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois
on ne peut pas savoir exactement quelles
conditions il a été déclenché mais il
faut le déclencher de toute façon le
plus vite possible
c'est à chaque fois une vie d'enfant qui
est en jeu en novembre dernier le
parquet d'angers avait déjà expérimenté
un dispositif similaire au plan alerte
enlèvement
ils avaient permis de retrouver la
petite aurélia en 24 heures aux états
unis où le système amber alert est en
place depuis 1996 plus de 140 enfants
ont été retrouvés après le crash de
l'airbus en sibérie ce matin en 9è on
évoque une panne du système de freinage
de l'appareil
mais l'enquêté ne fait que commencer
c'est à l'atterrissage que l'avion a
pris feu selon un tout dernier bilan
près de 122 morts et 50 blessés
à irkoutsk près du lac baïkal and
continue pendant des heures les
secouristes ont découpé la carcasse
fumante de l'airbus pour dégager les
corps des passagers la plupart d'entre
eux sont morts brûlés
juste après l'atterrissage l'avion a
quitté la piste percuté des bâtiments de
l'aéroport et s'est embrasé
à peine plus d'une soixantaine de
passagers ont échappé aux flammes et ont
pu raconter les dernières minutes avant
l'accident
l'avion a glissé d'après ce que m'a
raconté ma fille il a glissé et puis il
a repris la vitesse de plus en plus vite
puis freiné brutalement tout le monde a
été projeté à l'avant mon petit fils m'a
dit que ceux qui ont ouvert les portes
de secours en premier ont brûlé selon
une agence russes citant un membre de la
commission denquête le système de
freinage est en cause il a été actionné
par le pilote
il ad'abord fonctionner fusent il est
tombé en panne mais cette explication
n'est pas validée officiellement la dîme
outin a ordonné de déterminer les causes
de l'accident et décrété une journée de
deuil national demain pour l'heure le
bilan reste incertain
apparemment quelques personnes
voyageaient sans figurer sur la liste et
quelques rescapés ont fui sans être
enregistrées par les secours
le nombre de morts est donc d'environ
140 personnes quatorze enfants se
trouvaient à bord six d'entre eux au
moins sont rescapés
c'est la deuxième catastrophe aérienne
en russie en à peine trois mois
on met un airbus a320 arménien s'était
abîmé en mer noire juste avant son
atterrissage à sotchi
les boîtes noires n'avaient pas décelé
davari à ce jour les causes de
l'accident restent inconnues
l'avr des sans papiers dans les enfants
scolarisés en france sont menacées
d'expulsion continue d'occuper
l'actualité par solidarité un certain
nombre de familles se sont mobilisés
pour parrainer des enfants qui risquent
d'être renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine
à l'exemple de ces familles bretonnes
qui cache une petite fille de six ans
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
l'enfant n'entre pas dans les critères
de régularisation
mallory aoun au chili + 1 elle est
arrivé sans prévenir
et derrière une maison qui n'est pas la
sienne elle retrouve clandestinement sa
fille sakina tamir alieva est sous le
coup d'un arrêté d'expulsion pour le
déjouer elle n'a trouvé qu'un moyen cash
et patti matt six ans car elle ne peut
être renvoyé sans elle après cinq ans de
démarches entre l'allemagne et la france
une expulsion signifierait un retour au
daguestan son pays d'origine elle ne
peut l'envisager
j'ai eu un enfant mariage là bas ce sont
des musulmans et c'est puni par la loi
comme ma fille me dit maman je veux être
avec toi je lui dis que si nous sommes
ensemble nous serons de nouveau renvoyé
moufles que nous devons être patients
c'est difficile pour elle mais elle me
dit maman j'attendrai je sais que tu
m'aimes cette séparation sakina tu ne
l'as pas imaginé seuls parents d'élèves
enseignants un mouvement de solidarité
est née dans l'école de sa fille ils
organisent la cache égrène des rappels
devant la préfecture leur qg une salle
de classe
la pétition a recueilli près de 6000
signatures le comité de soutien contenu
sion adhérents c'était important pour
nous de les aider
je veux dire cette petite fille je la
croisais tous les jours la compagnie
toutes les sorties scolaires en un mois
et se débrouiller parfaitement française
totalement loin de nous imaginer sa
situation quoi cacher depuis plus de
trois mois
batimat n'a pas revu ses camarades avant
les vacances ils se sont contentés de
lettres et de dessins bien que
parfaitement intégrée elle ne
bénéficiera pas des mesures de
régularisation prévu par nicolas sarkozy
elle a été scolarisée trop récemment
loin des remous administratif batimat
passe donc d'une maison à l'autre on
peut pas rester en france là moi je
terminais et pour qu'un jour ces rêves
se réalisent ces familles d'accueil
prennent de gros risques
il faut quelques trois ans de prison
quelque trente mille euros même plus
mais ça j'y pense pas voilà pour moi ça
ne pose pas trop de problèmes et j'ai
pas peur la désobéissance civile pour
que batimat obtiennent un titre de
séjour au moins provisoire qu'elle
retrouve sa mère et à la rentrée
prochaine le chemin de l'école dans le
sud l'alerté à la canicule était tendu
un troisième département sont concernés
donc par cette vigilance orange le gard
les bouches-du-rhône et le vaucluse
mardi on attend des pointes à 38° cette
vague de chaleur qui pourrait durer
jusqu'à jeudi nécessite de prendre les
précautions indispensables pour les plus
fragiles yannick à rossi christophe la
roque à 28 degrés en bord de mer à
marseille cet après midi pas de quoi
dissuader les adeptes du jogging
l'égalité à chaleur
c'est pas très grave encore le matin que
l'après-midi les forces en ces temps de
canicule l'activité physique n'est pas
recommandé pourtant tout cas vous
pouvoir
mon joker doute à la mer qui pensent
qu'en buvant un litre et demi plus il
est protégé parce qu'il va aller
transpirer
s'il court 2 heures par cette
température il va transpirer au moins
quatre voire six voire huit litres d'eau
s'il continue 25 degrés dès ce matin au
réveil le bonheur des singles mais sous
la tente on frise la surchauffe
déjà fatigué coup de chaleur je supporte
liés à la canicule
ici on est bien et ses ombrages et
d'asseoir une cela ça est déjà reparti
sur la plage du cassis les pompiers ont
un oeil sur les baigneurs et l'autre sur
les personnes à risque et les rayons
pascal
et c'est rentré on pense à la crème
solaire mais c'est vrai que l'on boit
sur mon passé où des gens qui font de la
route qui viennent nous voir sur la
plage et qui pense à s'exploser toute la
journée
et là c'est vrai que souvent des
malaises liés à la chaleur
l'alerté canicule devrait durer jusqu'à
jeudi
les températures vont continuer de
grimper elle pourrait atteindre 38
degrés dans l'arrière-pays mardi
après-midi chapitre médical sachez que
l'assurance maladie prend en charge
depuis une semaine cet examen qui sert à
mesurer la densité osseuse sont
concernés bien sûr les personnes âgées
mais pas seulement car mieux vaut
prévenir l'ostéoporose dès que possible
josé blanc lapierre wernig danse percer
le secret d eau avec des rayons x de
faible intensité
voilà le principe du densité mettre un
appareil capable de sonder la masse
osseuse et de vérifier si sa densité
diminue avec l'âge
car comme beaucoup de femmes
marie-france bardot passé la
cinquantaine se sent plus fragiles
quand je descends les marches c'est très
attention je me tiens la rampe pour pas
évidemment une pépite tomber et me
casser le coaching vous avez donc
intérêt à poursuivre un traitement
adéquat ostéoporose annonce le médecin
autrement dit un déficit au ce qui va
pouvoir être traitées médicaments mais
aussi l'hygiène de vie avec de
l'activité physique et de l'huile de
foie de morue de la vitamine d qui fixe
le calcium mais le plus important est
d'avoir pu anticiper sur l'évolution de
la maladie
on a toujours l'habitude de dire qu' il
faut mieux traiter une hypertension
artérielle
plutôt que d'attendre là que l'arrivée
d'un accident vasculaire cérébral
eh bien c'est la même chose il faut
traiter une ostéoporose sans fracture
avant l'arrivée de cette fameuse
fracture fixé à 39 euros 90 est
désormais remboursée par la sécurité
sociale
le dépistage de l'ostéoporose s'adresse
en priorité aux femmes à risque des
femmes ayant déjà subi une fracture un
traitement à base de cortisone ou encore
une longue immobilisation
le quart des femmes de plus de 50 ans
est concernée nouvelles mesures en
faveur de la famille avec ce nouveau
congé parental plus court et mieux
rémunéré en principe il s'adresse aux
parents qui hésitent à faire un
troisième enfant et ving oehlmann lionel
langlade garde de son enfant ou
travailler un choix toujours difficile
pour les parents quand on décide de
travailler crèche ou nourrices ils font
payer
je suis très très bien mais je touche
plus du double que 750 euros pour deux
enfants garde partagée jusqu'ici à
partir du deuxième enfant
on pouvait s'arrêter trois ans et
toucher 513 euros par mois maintenant à
partir du troisième enfant il existe un
congé plus court mieux payé 750 euros
par mois pendant un an
ça peut intéresser des couples salariés
qui veulent accueillir mieux leurs
enfants leur troisième enfant et qui
veulent ne pas distendre le lien
professionnel qui les relie à leur
entreprise et qui souhaitent à congés
assez rémunérés tout temps de pertes en
par le lien avec l'entreprise donc pour
faciliter la vie la conciliation vie
familiale vie professionnelle
les ronny qu'a choisi de partager avec
ses trois enfants les premiers moments
de leur vie ils ont 54 ans et le petit
dernier moins d'un an
enfin le frêle environ vite rappeur par
jour
enfin lever le matin l'un est couché
animeront les cauchemars actuellement
elle bénéficie d'un congé parental de 3
ans 1 513 euros par mois le nouveau
dispositif ne lui plaît pas les frais de
garde temps que d'année n'est pas
scolarisé serait énorme
et en fait j'avais que je travaille pour
ça bon salaire et passerait pour elle le
congé parental de trois ans reste malgré
tout plus attrayant et pour revenir sur
le marché du travail une formation ou
une remise à niveau serait une meilleure
solution
la fin du voyage de benoît 16 en espagne
le pape à valence a célébré une messe
devant des centaines de milliers de
pèlerins insistant une nouvelle fois sur
les valeurs traditionnelles de la
famille et du mariage chrétien pas de
vraie critique ouverte concernant les
réformes de l'espagne socialiste qui
autorise le mariage homosexuel mais le
chef du gouvernement josé luis zapatero
a choisi de ne pas être présents à la
messe de clôture au mexique le candidat
de la gauche battue de justesse par son
adversaire de droite lepez obrador ne
reconnaît toujours pas la victoire de
felipe calderon et il a décidé de se
tourner vers la justice et appelle à la
résistance civile à mexico cent mille
manifestants sont descendus dans la rue
cyr disent qu'ils défendent la
démocratie dénonçant de nombreuses
fraudes électorales dans ce pays
d'énormes chantiers attendent celui qui
va prendre les rênes du pouvoir et en
particulier l'insécurité
mexico est en tête des villes les plus
dangereuses du monde les crimes et les
enlèvements sont pratiques courantes
allen seulement depuis 11 mois rodolfo
martinez doigts et niasse villa dans 70
qu'il a plantés sur ce trottoir de
mexico juste devant les bureaux du
procureur général
son objectif attirer l'attention sur le
sort de son frère alejandro disparu il
ya cinq ans
quatre véhicules de gendarmes et on est
moins fort militaire ou de la police les
ont fait mon frère un ami et les ont
emmenés en direction de mexico alejandro
est une des innombrables victimes de la
violence extrême du mexique meurtres et
enlèvements trois ou quatre par jour en
moyenne pour la seule capitale sont
monnaies courantes pour le peut dans
l'est mais pour 3 pesos 3 millions de
dollars 2 % des tous les crimes sont
punis alors impunité énorme globale des
patrouilles lourdement armées sillonnent
pourtant la ville de mexico trente huit
mille hommes sont affectés à ces actions
dites de police préventives
ici c'est le secteur sud de la capitale
un quartier plutôt calme paiement on a
surtout à faire dans ce quartier à une
délinquance traditionnel des délinquants
individuelles qui agit seul on a pas de
bandes criminelles organisées mais il y
a quelques points chauds qu'on a décelé
où on vend de la drogue
la tactique est simple intervenir dès le
moindre soupçon quitte la prise et le
délit de sale gueule ici par exemple une
bm suspecte et c'est une voiture de luxe
et le chauffeur n'a pas l'air d'avoir
les moyens de l'aimer tel voiture en
l'occurrence les occupants de la bm
n'avait rien à se reprocher mais c'est
ainsi d'après le lieutenant qu'on fait
tomber la délinquance la petite
délinquance
curieusement dans ce pays le thème de la
lutte contre l'insécurité est mise au
crédit de la gauche la droite étant
souvent soupçonné à tort ou à raison de
liens avec les gangs et en particulier
avec les narcotrafiquants
on n'ira que nouvelles attaques contre
la communauté sunnite à bagdad ce sont
des hommes armés masqués qui ont
installé un faux barrage semble-t-il
ils ont fait descendre les
automobilistes et ils les ont exécutés
42 personnes au moins ont été
assassinées par ailleurs les ravisseurs
d'une député sunnite exige la libération
de 25 détenus dans les prisons
américaines aux états unis précisément
où l'armée américaine vient d'inculper
cinq de ses soldats pour le viol et le
meurtre d'une adolescente irakienne et
de sa famille une nouvelle affaire qui
s'ajoute à d'autres actes de violence
sur les populations commises par des
gi's à moscou vladimir poutine a
dialogué pendant plus de deux heures sur
internet
répondant à toutes sortes de questions
de la tchétchénie au missile nord-coréen
du plus anecdotique aux plus graves une
opération de relations publiques sur la
toile en poussines et l'admirent poutine
s'est livré à bien d exercice de
communication mais là c'est une première
un chat sur internet
retransmis sur une petite chaîne câblée
et sur la bbc objectif moderniser son
image à la veille du g8
première question sur la corée du nord
le président russe préoccupé appel au
compromis mais sur la crise du gaz avec
l'ukraine
il choisit l'humour combien coûte votre
collier centaines de roquettes
alors il m'a choqué vous me levant
driller pour 5 kopecks casque à pied
tchétchénie pauvreté service militaire
tout y passe sans tabou problème les
internautes ont parfois des
préoccupations un peu décalé la
quatrième question la plus posée concert
cette pieuvre de science fiction et la
troisième question portait sur le bisou
sur le ventre donné par vladimir poutine
la semaine dernière un petit garçon qui
se promenaient au kremlin il m'a semblé
indépendant et sérieux à gc mais en même
temps m avec cette vulnérabilité des
enfants maxime doit protéger
incheon ils étaient tous mignons et les
mauvaises langues prétendent que ce
geste ait cette conférence de presse
d'un nouveau genre sont l'oeuvre du
cabinet de relations publiques
américains payés pour améliorer l'image
du kremlin à la fin hors antenne
vladimir poutine a répondu à la dixième
question sur sa première expérience
sexuelle de la première je ne me
souviens pas at il dit mais de la
dernière où il à la minute près
qu'on se le dise la russie aussi à un
président ouvert à toutes sortes de
questions
françois hollande en algérie le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste s'est
longuement entretenu avec abdelaziz
bouteflika entre la gauche française et
le pouvoir algérien le courant est passé
alexandre kara ses vins doba
ali g si le capitaine de l'équipe
socialiste est bien accueilli c'est
zizou l'homme du jour
et lorsque le dialogue s'est garé vers
la politique ce sont toujours les mêmes
thèmes visa loi sur la décolonisation
kärcher oui alors et bal à alléger
deuxième ville francophone du monde a
réservé un accueil de chefs vivent pas
au patron du parti socialiste plus de
trois heures d'entretien avec le
président bouteflika
l'occasion pour françois hollande de
marteler sa différence sur le chapitre
coloniale qui seraient à nous convaincre
le système colonial qui n'a aucun
caractère positif et qui ne peut pas en
avoir puisque la colonisation
ces occupations d'un pays par l'eau et
l'exploitation pour une grande partie de
la presse algérienne il s'agit d'un
changement de cap
alger se tournent désormais vers la
gauche c'est un rendez vous tout à fait
partisan ça bien d'entre eux mêmes d'une
prise de courant je crois que
chirac roulage il est en veilleuse mais
derrière cette visite de françois
hollande il ya un autre enjeu celui des
millions d'électeurs français sensibles
à la question algérienne un électorat
que le parti socialiste bien séduire à
dix mois de la présidentielle apparaît
dans le 6e arrondissement inauguration
de la place michel debré en présence de
jacques chirac du maire de paris du
président de l'assemblée nationale l'un
des 4 6 de celui qui fut l'un des
fondateurs de la vème république et
ainsi dell du général de gaulle à
quelques jours du traditionnel décider
du 14 juillet les chars leclerc
reprennent du service s'ils seront à la
parade sur les champs-elysées jérôme
solar nicolas rançon première répétition
avant la grande parade vendredi à 12
kilomètres/heure précisément aligné
comme un seul homme
trente deux chars leclerc de la 2e db
avant le grand défilé du 14 juillet
des chars leclerc sur les champs-elysées
ce n'est pas une première en 2003 année
de la canicule le béton avait fondu sous
le soleil et sous les chenilles du
mastodonte bilan 190 mille euros de
réparations sur les pavés parisiens à la
charge du contribuable
cette année c'est promis ça devrait bien
se passer pas de fortes chaleurs
annoncées et des conducteurs de chars
plus souple et plus doux qui ont
travaillé leur virage ça se passera bien
le des chats sont de pavés s'est passé
sur une zone très restreinte l'armée à
payer les dégâts à la suite le lendemain
matin il en était plus rien je pense que
même s'il devait y avoir quelques pavés
des chaussées remets-toi chauffeur place
les chars leclerc mérite le champs
elysées le char leclerc une merveille de
technologie française
un blindé de 56 tonnes qui tire en
mouvement à 80 km/heure climatisés dotés
d'une vision nocturne
il est l'un des plus performants au
monde l'un des plus chers au 6 à 8
millions d'euros l'unité
un char très mal vendu à l'exportation
il a été livré trop tard en 93
après la chute du mur de berlin
qu'à cela ne tienne pour le grand
spectacle du 14 juillet vendredi les
français pourront l'admirer sur la plus
belle avenue du monde malgré les
critiques le leclerc tiendra son rang ni
trop vite ni trop doucement les pavés de
la capitale devrait bien se tenir
la coupe du monde des jeux vidéo a
remporté un gros succès à paris un
marché en pleine expansion 12 millions
de passionnés se connectent pour jouer
en ligne nicolas chateauneuf valérie cas
à singapour elles forment la meilleure
équipe de soldats virtuels
de passage à paris elle joue encore et
encore abri malines tension réflexes
dans sept salles de jeux parisiennes
s'entraînent les meilleurs joueurs
pourtant certains semblent ailleurs et
pour cause ils sont plongés dans un
univers entièrement virtuelle un monde
dit persistant un nouveau type de jeux
vidéo qui compte déjà 12 millions
d'adeptes dans le monde
de réfugiés sur la route berkane
traduction le personnage créé par ce
joueur évolue sur internet dans un monde
peuplé de milliers d'autres joueurs amis
ou ennemis au programme des défis des
aventures des monstres et des pouvoirs
magiques
chaque personnage en fait se cache une
personne se cache à un joueur en fait
derrière son écran comme moi
actuellement et qui sont un peu partout
dans le monde une nouvelle manière de
jouer sur mesure qui remporte un succès
foudroyant des aventures on partage ce
monde avec d'autres gens et quand ils s
arrêtent de jouer la partie continue les
autres gens continuent à jouer on peut
revenir quand on veut
le monde est vraiment indépendant du
joueur avec ou sans abonnement le joueur
achète donc l'accès à un univers virtuel
dans lequel des libre d'évoluer à son
rythme la formule à un tel succès
qu'elles débordent parfois dans la vie
réelle certains clients fait se
rassemblent avec des spécificités en mai
gens qui ont des personnages ou des
magiciens se rassemblent en magicien d
oz se rassemblent en orc et puis à ce
moment-là eux communiquent en dehors du
en dehors du jeu
l'industrie du jeu vidéo pèse
aujourd'hui plus louvre que celle du
cinéma doter de nouveaux moyens les
concepteurs ne se contentent donc plus
de parties linéaire mais créer de toutes
pièces des univers entier dans lequel le
joueur peut vivre sa vie de héros
virtuels et casser la baraque dans la
limite du raisonnable bien sûr la finale
hommes de wimbledon c'est roger federer
qui a remporté le tournoi pour la
quatrième fois de suite il a battu
rafael nadal en quatre sets 6/0 7/6 6/7
6/3 arnaud compte quatre finales en
quatre ans 4 victoires pour rodger
federer
le maître du gazon londonien le suisse a
pris sa revanche sur rafael nadal
vainqueur il ya un mois en finale de
roland garros
la partie s'annonce est coriace mais
dans le premier set federer domine le
débat début de match spectaculaire du
numéro un mondial
il inflige à l'espanyol 1 6 0 en
seulement 24 minutes
dans la deuxième manche nadal mène 5
jeux à 3 mais federer opiniâtre recolle
au score et l'emporter finalement au tie
break
difficile de s'en relever pour nadal
mais le double vainqueur de
roland-garros en a encore dans le
cordage
tel un conquistador rejette ses forces
dans le troisième set qu'il gagne 7 jeux
à 6
mais cet après midi il en fallait plus
pour arrêter un rodger federer
revanchard
le suisse s'impose en quatre sets 6/0
7/6 6/7 6/3 et avec quatre succès
rejoint pete sampras au sommet de
wimbledon
la 8e étape du tour de france 180 km
entre saint mélo grand et lorient c'est
un français qui a remporté l'épreuve
il s'agit de la deuxième victoire
française dans le tour
nathanaël de rincquesen josé boulesteix
à événement exceptionnel encouragements
exceptionnel
cet après midi sur les routes bretonnes
le public affiché fièrement ses couleurs
du bleu du blanc du rouge tout le monde
signe forcément dans un tel contexte pas
étonnant de retrouver des français aux
avant postes patrice halgand et sylvain
calzati faussé compagnie au peloton en
compagnie d'un belge d'un allemand d'un
américain et d'un suédois depuis le
début du tour
les fuyards sont systématiquement repris
pas aujourd'hui
rina bel effort à 30 kilomètres de
l'arrivée sylvain calzati accélère et
décide de partir seul conquérir son
premier succès sur le tour
calzati et un français d'origine
italienne
à quelques heures de la finale de la
coupe du monde rien ne pouvait lui faire
plus plaisir que de franchir la ligne de
lorient seul en tête avec plus de deux
minutes d'avancé sur le peloton
je ne me serais jamais douté de partir
et d'arrivée seul comme ça avec 30 km
d'effort solitaire mais bon j'avais les
bonnes gens mais je pense que c'est un
jour magnifique pour moi
au classement général on de charles
ukrainien conserve la première place et
découvrent les plaisirs de la vie en
jaune
les supporteurs français eux ont le
sourire la journée a plutôt bien
commencé le festival d'avignon avec cet
autoportrait d'un danseur de hip hop ou
le parcours d'un fils d'immigrés
algériens qui rencontre la danse et les
mots un spectacle intitulé faut qu'on en
parle à peine mostefa marque de la gana
guèye sur les murs d'avignon on y danse
on y dans huit pop n'est pas seulement
et c'est justement là que ça devient
intéressant on peut plus danser comme
avant on sait que les mots sont venus
aussi se rajouter et on se disait que
j'en étais une génération qui ne
connaissions pas notre histoire
génération rassemblement qu'il fallait
parler de la réalité que nous parents
avaient pas pu prendre la parole lors
que nous aujourd'hui fallait qu'on la
prenne et encore plus aujourd'hui dans
ce contexte actuel hamid ben mahi est
dans la place
dans la chapelle des pénitents blancs il
va raconter l'histoire d'un jeune homme
coloré la propre histoire
ma mère avait passé son permis
elle avait acheté une simca 1000 c'était
fort pour une femme du bled elle
travaillait dans les trains elle est
nettoyé elle a fait beaucoup de métier
comme ça où elle nettoyer sa naissance à
talence sa jeunesse dans la cité des
aubiers à bordeaux avec rage tendresse
ironie c'est la chronique ordinaire d'un
fils d'immigrés algériens toujours
aujourd'hui se passait pas grand chose
aux biens et sont venus organiser le
championnat du monde de bmx
ils sont venus des quatre coins du monde
d'australie du japon de suède
c'était la première fois que je voyais
un vélo avec un cadre carré nous on
n'avait pas les moyens de s'acheter un
vélo un pourquoi il avait organisé ça
chez nous entre deux pas de danse images
des anecdotes s'enchaînent jamais
misérabiliste toujours avec l'énergie de
ceux qui veulent qui croire
c'était ce qu'on vit dans sin city quoi
qu'on y fait beau aujourd'hui on a
besoin aussi de se dire que qu'on a
notre place qu'on est né ici qu'on a des
choses à faire qu'on a du talent et il
ya des jeunes qui ont eu toute une
jeunesse qui a du talent il faut leur
montrer pour les pousser faut les
pousser faut qu'on parle un mythe ben
mallet volontaires vrais danseurs vrai
conteur il veut le micro et pas
seulement quand zidane fait gagner
l'équipe de france le festival de photo
d'arles joue les noctambules avec ses
projections sur les places et dans les
cours la photo en fait isabelle bessler
didier guérin les rues du quartier de la
roquette sont bondés comme un soir de
feria quand les rencontres
internationales de la photo prennent les
arlésiens par la main avec un sens de la
fête
extrêmement contagieux les amateurs de
photos déambulent entre 13 projections
gratuites et autres initiatives
ce sont des agences de photo les
quotidiens et des magazines qui ont
concocté cette heure de projection au
total la grande passion du moment n'est
donc jamais très loin
on peut rentrer dans des festivals sans
être nécessairement féru de photographie
ou instruit de l'histoire de la
photographie c'est accessible à tout le
monde pour nous c'est de la façon de
faire le pont avec cette promenade
festival nuits avec aussi les
expositions qui sont en ville et de la
photo variés mode paysage au reportage a
donc été vue jusqu'au bout de la nuit
par plus de dix mille noctambules de
circonstance une photo à la carte non
intimidante qu'on peut quitter ou
attendre de revoir selon l'humeur du
moment
c'est incroyable parler tout bien
surprenant c'est historique on retrouve
de la photo en chêne contemporaine
c'est une expérience très forte pendant
très longtemps les rencontres photos
elles ont été à ce point justement loin
les arlésiens je pense que cette
initiative c'est vraiment à une
réconciliation c'est la deuxième année
et en fait on dirait un gros très
facilement il faudra attendre l'édition
2007 maintenant pour de nouvelles
collisions nocturne avec la photo dans
les rues du vieil arles
là où les écrans de projection vous
berce et au rythme du souffle du mistral
la mode haute couture automne hiver 2007
paris reste la capitale est la vitrine
des collections avec sur les podiums les
créations des plus grands couturiers de
lagerfeld à la croix et celle cola
mathieu dreujou grégory vasseur fils
coupe à l'instinct draps placement à
même le corps sont des 500 patrons un
numéro de haute voltige
elie saab le couturier fétiche de la
reine rania de jordanie vend 4 à 5 fois
plus de modèles que ses concurrents
entre 800 et 1000 robe pâle en lui
c'est une formule je crois que nous
sommes les maisons qui vont de plus de
robes haute couture au monde
ses robes entre 13 et 300000 euros pièce
à 42 ans couturier libanais est en train
de construire un empire avec ses robes
des mille et une nuits après le liban
l'italie valentino 73 ans inoxydable
valentino est un seigneur à chevalier de
ces dames un serviteur d'une certaine
élégance depuis maintenant 45 ans
vous savez moi je suis quelqu'un qui
n'avait pas s'exprimer si je pars créant
par la main alors avec mon crayon
j'étudie je fais de ligne je fais des
ddd très et voilà c'est comme ça que les
nouvelles arrivent robe de bal de tapis
rouge de gala du grand soir son terrain
de jeu favori
point de jet setteur pour riccardo tisci
chez givenchy son registre grade
terriblement élégant tout sans même
parfois ses créations jusqu'à
l'hostilité de mettre quelque chose dans
les ateliers ont travaillé avec leur
savoir faire traditionnels
cette collection ultra contemporaine du
plus jeune des couturiers chez christian
lacroix le somptueux tutoie l'exquis la
simplicité le tempérament
la sérénité le crissement des couleurs
l e
vingt ans de maison et aujourd'hui
pléthore de clientes pour cette couture
à nulle autre pareille qui n'a jamais
perdu son âme
c'est des gros chiffres des grosses ou
d'activités ces dames salariés autour de
moi mais en même temps ça tient parce
que justement c'est complètement
impalpable
au final une fluide osier blanc s'est
abattue sur ce magicien les yankees à
laudun des échasses pong fastueux
défilés
et puis il y a les détails qui changent
tout comme ses souliers haute couture
digne de cendrillon quelques centaines
d'heures de travail par les meilleurs
artisans brodeur au projet vivier revu
et corrigé par bruno frisoni du grand
art à prix d'or pour se situe plutôt
autour de 7000 euros disons c'est comme
par là où on commence audry toujours
chez chanel où la technique de
construction l'inimitable coup de patte
les prouesses de l'invisible fond de
karl lagerfeld un des maîtres de la
haute couture comme une antenne est
tellement sur l'image on capte tout et
puis on préfère la sa façon italie
toujours le geste est efficace tendre
une bonne tête en dessous de ses
mannequins giorgio armani 72 ans prépare
son quatrième défilé couture
je me contente pas de faire du bruit
autour de moi avec le pour le futur mais
d'avoir en même temps résultats
colombie le résultat armani est l'une
des marques les plus convoités de la
planète entre 18 et 80000 euros pièce
armani c'est le miracle à l'italienne
dans la course également la relève il y
à 7 ans franck sorbier sacré couturier
depuis déboule dans cet atelier de
riches clients qui littéralement hâtée
par ces ornementations son graphisme sa
poésie même mylène farmer et johnny
hallyday sont accros ya plus d'anonymat
je dire là on est on est que je crois
vraiment dans le rapport humain ça aussi
la culture
quant à jean paul gaultier le magicien
et conteur
c'est l'essence même de la couture
parisienne
moi j'adore sur scène ce thriller l
univers un ton est toujours des
surprises comme ça vraiment formidable a
lancé un grand couturier
les français ont toujours aimé la
fantaisie de gaultier qu'elle ils
viennent la tour eiffel le café crème l
exploit ce temps voilà c'est le mélange
de la fourrure label la bête la belle la
paix comme elle n'a même
après tout depuis 30 ans date de la
création de sa maison
il fait partie du patrimoine collecte
mais la palme de l'inventivité revient à
john galliano pour dior
home de faire le bras d'armure tailleur
années 40
tout le génie de galliano
si le même écart mu et voyager un peu
partout ça avec tout le monde tous mes
équipes
on commence avec dans l'ordre
m
clash délire contes et légendes
un show époustouflant pour un couturier
turbulent part ensuite et chez dior
il y a juste dit vent
cinéma avec la sortie du premier film
sur les attentats du 11-septembre vol 93
raconte le courage de ses passagers qui
ont tenté de prendre le contrôle de
l'avion qui s'est écrasé en pennsylvanie
une reconstitution qui se veut très
réaliste parce qu'elle deschamps raimu
poissonnier qui ont percuté le world
trade center
leur avion a été détourné de cuisine
demi heure lorsque les passagers du vol
93 apprennent ce qui s'est passé à new
york
il faut la tenter
à partir de leurs appels de leurs
messages le film montre en temps réel
comment ils ont tenté de prendre le
contrôle de l'appareil
on y va
quarante passagers livrés à eux mêmes et
au sol la pagaille absolue aux dents vol
93 bus lines qui joue son propre rôle à
bertoua pour savoir ce qui se passe sur
1 ce matin du 11 septembre sont
responsables du contrôle aérien a vécu
le plus grand drame mais aussi le plus
grand échec de sa vie
c'est pas vrai vous avez vu ce qui est
arrivé
c'était le cas au fond moi ce fut une
terrible frustration de ne pas savoir ce
qui se passait il s'est contenté de
subir de réagir sans rien contrôler
quand vous êtes contrôleurs aériens la
dernière chose que vous voulez faire
c'est vous contenter de réagir
loin de tout sensationnalisme paul
greengrass a voulu nous replonger dans
l'événement parce que dit-il
nous n'en avons pas encore tiré les
leçons le problème de la colère le
problème de l'engagement des musulmans
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
si nous voulons vraiment nous y
confronter cela demande des changements
profonds dans nos sociétés nous gérons
le monde ne veut pas on préfère
s'occuper de la coupe du monde où les
vacances
consultez dès la préparation du film les
familles des passagers ont apporté un
soutien sans réserve vol 93 est un grand
film à 10,1 critiques américains
résumant ainsi le sentiment général et
j'en ai détesté chaque seconde
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
remercie de votre attention tout de
suite la météo nathalie rihouet 20h50
coliques et puis la france en bleu à
23h15 une édition spéciale après la
finale du mondial au tour de david
pujadas
de nombreux invités nous serons bien sûr
en direct des champs elysées et des
grandes villes de france excellence
vincent est sûre français